we're not even considering you having
any albums out yet
yeah call it what you want but I I feel
like I have it put out an album yet like
I haven't sat down and genuinely been
like album mode everything I've been
making been on the move so like now you
put out the four pack just to kind of
appease everybody you're like yo I got
these four we did it before obviously
yeah uh this is kind of the appetizer to
the debut albums the appetizer and you
could tell too I'm staying true to my
sound right but for the for the album
it's gonna be more experimental it's
definitely still staying true to myself
for the album too but it's an elevator
version of that so I'm excited for the
fans so I feel like they can predict
what I'm doing but I'm gonna hit them
with a left jab real quick I was gonna
say how are you experimenting because I
do feel like
you have your signature sound yeah you
have your I feel like you have your
pocket if we think of like what a blast
BPM is like kind of know what your
pocket is how are you expanding the
sound how are you experimenting man well
for me it's just opening my mind to
different creators as well right A lot
of the times I'll be in the house by
myself like it's only so much
inspiration you can pull from a bedroom
in isolation right right so I'm opening
uh my mind with different writers
different producers different creatives
even just people with good conversation
I'm just you know putting myself more
out there I'll be to myself a lot so you
know it's a challenge for me but I'm
willing to go over that hump would you
say your introvert
I'm like an introvert extrovert like if
you know me you know I'm goofy you know
I'm actually talking and playful but you
know the people I'm not really
comfortable with it may take some time
for me to get open with you you and
Roddy Rich are very similar definitely
yeah yeah we just we just shot the video
to passionate and I was like y'all got
to open up more he was like you know we
two [__]
[Laughter]
shout out right here let's give people
yo this is an amazing jacket shout out
to Jeff Hamilton you said this is a
custom Jack Hamilton Jeff Hamilton man
we did a you know a custom piece for the
before you go to our merch so fans
bought this too yeah what's that at
least a rack 1200 1500. you feel that
leather man no I know listen I know
regular he made his son's jacket and I
put it on at my boy shop guest list in
Phoenix
and then he was like it's 1200 and I
took it right off and put it back I said
that shout out to Jeff man shout out
Jeff man he good people yeah um for you
how are you guys expanding the Eagle
brand because if it's going to be kind
of a quiet year for you after this four
pack working on the album or you guys uh
gonna be putting out artists I know
we've talked to you guys have had you
guys signed artists obviously we talked
about that last time is there going to
be any music coming out it's gonna be a
lot of things coming on us Vic likes
likes to say we like to keep the channel
noisy right so we got the Venture side
of Eagle we got the publish inside of
Eagle we got the label side
um we got artists like Jay million that
we developing we got producers and
artists like Grandmaster Vic Jay pilot
so we pushing them out in different
Endeavors as well they're gonna be
working on my project too but um and
then we got the you know the investment
side of things we we have here on that
side too uh what are you guys investing
in we got the creative wreck in Philly
okay what's that um Philly wreck Philly
it's the Creator for gems I mean it's a
gym for creators my bad so when you say
it's a gym for creatives yeah it's like
where people who are creative go to like
lift weights not hell
it's like it's like a workshop for
creators so you may go in you may want
to yo you could come here you could lift
weights No One's Gonna judge you if you
got paint on your hands and [__]
nah it's like a gym for creators so when
I say say that it's like a workshop
where you may link with somebody who
know how to print up some merch or you
may link with somebody who's a producer
or you know somebody who's on a brand
new side of things yeah so it's like the
hub for that but they also just
partnered with uh with Diddy for Miami
Rec as well so you're a part of that or
you're just part of the Philly location
we part of the whole thing oh yeah yeah
so check you out in business with Diddy
kind of yes so literally you could say
that have you ever talked to Diddy no
not personally why not
I mean it never it's just your blast it
hasn't been hard to encountered yet what
are you talking about I'm pretty sure
we're gonna run into each other someday
he's supposed to be putting out an r b
album man he going crazy with Jazzy too
love records they going stupid you got
to be on the Diddy r b album yeah I work
with Jazzy shout out Jazzy